basically
I led you to believe that I was in
London and coming to India and then
you were being kind of flirtatious and I
guess the real question is
why did you send me a photo of you with
no shirt on
it was a post
but you sent it to me I just forwarded
you
it felt to me I felt that that was
inappropriate
you agreed to meet up with me
okay so the thing is when you message me
she already told me about like both of
you so I know about all of you basically
from the picnic
I thought like a you are guys pulling my
leg at that time
and uh
I said okay
let's do something
so I was also like uh pulling your leg
at that moment okay
and uh
I wanted to like call over there because
I wanted to know that uh you are alone
over there you are with Myra you are
with Jane or something like that what is
going on over there so that's why I want
to clear it on the phone okay yeah but
you didn't call me you just blocked me
uh-huh you didn't say oh lol this was
just you know I know joke's on me
and so like why did you block me okay
and you deleted all of our chat history
which is a little shady so at that time
I was found like a okay I think uh this
conversation is going in a different
direction so I just uh Delete all this
so my block list is also long so your
block list is when you feel something's
inappropriate or not going the right way
yeah okay but do you message other girls
no okay but I I get the messages from
the girls you do get a lot of females
messaging you yeah still in the request
still in the request yeah let me show
you I've
it's all in request
so male and female you have such a
unique and sexy look I'm in London ATM
at the moment oh
who is that interesting
but did you respond to that person I
blocked them
well if he had something to hide he
wouldn't have shown you that that's true
[Music]